So for this assignment, discuss how you
might use incremental concept learning
to design an agent that can solve
Raven's progressive matrices.
What are the concepts that you're
trying to learn in this case?
What are you incrementing over?
This might depend on
the scope of your problem.
So are you doing concept learning at
the level of the individual problem?
Or are you doing it between problems?
What concepts are you learning here and
how are you actually
tweaking them over time?
What would a specific concept look like?
Or what would a general
concept look like?
Once you establish these concepts,
how will actually help
you solve knew problems?
Or how are you going to
instantiate them or
leverage them in new problems
that your agent faces?